ich habe ein weihnachtsgeschenk für dich
das kann nicht fliegen das ist kacke wie
ich befinde mich aber noch mein leben
des baskets ab
ich finde ich immer noch in statt rot
und wer meine freiheit am penis ist ja
immer noch oben auf deinem haus
warst du denn gebaut ja das gegen das
gesetz das in einer anderen stadt bonn
ist schon richtig richtig lange her der
übrigens auch vier eier
das ist ein besonderer blick sehen wirst
du ganz gut behandeln den versprechen
mit dreh ich bin dann aus wie niedlich
das ist so klein und kaká vor allem
dieser dieser haufen jeder ecke also ich
glaub ich da drauf krieg schaden
ja das ist zwar ein kleiner meine selten
eine kleine selbstkasteiung ecke
manchmal habe ich lust darauf und dann
stelle ich mich dahin und bekommt
schaden ist einfach mal habe ich lust
darauf bekommen
hey du wolltest mir einen hack
allerdings leben aber nur wenn du mir
einst apis kippe stand außerdem war
bescherung gestern ist nicht in england
bei uns geschenkt am 24 mein lieber
heute schon nach 25
guck doch mal aufs datum eingebaut die
kommen jetzt wieder nach hause kommen
jetzt mal mit zu uns hier erstmal hier
kommt man durch ok ich bin auf dem weg
hier unten ist irgendwo ein gang nach
und nach unten
so und jetzt sind wir wieder bei uns
nada dem betzenberg zeit die balance bei
uns hier läuft jeder staat hier läuft
nämlich nix zurzeit unser statt einfach
nur kaká im gegensatz zu eurer das echt
heftig jeder bot seinen eigenen style
ich glaube ich muss mein haus bald auch
in diesen style und bauen in dem die
hier schon in diesem haus haben in
diesem haus der crafter
beim skat weg
jetzt hast du dich ganz toll an
dankeschön
immer habe ich nicht irgendwie noch
jetzt hier irgendwie was sowie also wir
konnten jetzt nicht auf die kommentare
eingehen die ihr uns geschrieben hat
bezüglich friedensvertrag das wird dann
irgendwann einander vermisst wenigen
dass wir gerade auf im moment und morgen
fahre ich dann nach hause zu meiner
familie und da nehme ich eine woche lang
gar nicht drauf aber ist in dem wir
jetzt müssen was auch für euch auch
leder mit der maschine folgen habe leder
und rote wolle man im haus kann ich auch
blaue wollen nehmen sah ich die rolle
stutzen oder kuscheln ich wollte es mal
leder leder habe ich vor der disco blog
ist toll und dann hast du nur war ich
gesagt ich hatte das ding schon vorher
durch musste ich mir das jetzt weil er
sieht halt nicht aus wie ein blog dass
sie dann ein rundes stück kacke und da
dachte ich muss daraus eben den block
machen oder so sobald aber du hast sogar
bücherregale motto belesener mensch
parlament ich muss den anklamer bis
nichts
macht einfach alles offen kommt man habe
erwartet dass von den stalinisten das
sollte eigentlich keinen schaden machen
aber das witzig stell dich mal hierhin
ok seestern du kannst eigentlich gar
nicht am stock ist mein rad schaden
gemacht er aber du kannst nicht sterben
zwar eine granate darf in den noch ein
paar sachen kurz testen was zu bringen
guck mal was ich hab den bastian ich
habe ein weihnachtsgeschenk für dich das
kann nicht fliegen das ist kacke gelb
hätte es wenigstens mal eine fliege ding
machen kann
du kannst sie nehmen bei uns aber 99
grafik
ich möchte noch etwas alle testen
ständig hier hin wo bist du dich nicht
ich habe dir dein penis zurückgebracht
mein körper ist das denn eine bombe
gemacht habe anscheinend der penis ist
so hart köpfe zerredet zu haben
ich muss erwähnt habe ich dann die vier
habe ich dann etwas in rot dann bräuchte
rote blumen für oder
ja nicht um mich die roten blumen
scripting feld legen dann bekommen sie
so einen roten links raus was stamm
nutzen kann sonst von meyer um zu färben
du wolltest mich herum führen jetzt
stehe ich hier nur darum irgendwann
lehrer erst mal kurz tief aber machen
doch solche dem namen stehen können
viele sachen du hast schon edels viele
geschenkt bekommen forsting
ich habs nur so gesehen so sie mal
kommst du zu dir gibt diese lexika
diamond beste läuft das habe ich gar
nicht mitbekommen wirklich nicht was
ihre blumen weiß nicht dass senat und
nur nett von ihm nichts geschenkt
bekommen
lass dich langweilig niemand mag das
kann auch sein leben einfach unsere
stadt nicht tippe auf ersteres macht ihr
nichts aus
ja ich suche dich doch durch mein haus
oder wasser plötzlich weg ich bin bei
meinem alten haus bei der kirche da
stehen wir in die lüfte blöd zu spielen
die man ich bin bei den pimmel ich jetzt
dabei das waren grüne chocobos grüne
können gut über berge reiten und blaue
gut durch wasser schwimmen gibt auch
welche die alles kennen ja das goldene
echt
ich habe allerdings ist grün bisherigen
nutzern bälle sind dass das grün und
macht komische sachen voller thing
bisschen hilft wissen plötzlich eine
feder so zwei mexikaner diamond sind am
start
erstmal kommt die lücke bleibt das macht
das schoko waka waka waka portugiese
wieso heißt das behindert weil das mal
zombie und ich habe das so genannt weil
das man von komischen kopf hatte dass
sarah kempin wenig behindert aus dass
hatte den kopf hängen
ich gebe jetzt bisschen
bisschen ja ich habe schon mal zwei
teile von der fifa motto mein gott wie
wird sich das auf die fresse alter guck
dir das mal an aber schreibe ich jetzt
bitte nicht was michael tod bereit ist
auch behinderte wie das holz sieht ja
besser als sonst
videos sieht sich auf behinderungen die
hat einfach mal damals den kopf hängen
aber ich glaube dann hatten wir diesen
jungen fahrt ist auf ihr geritten und
dann okay war jetzt so cool eine einer
heißt auch gesichtsfalten gesicht ja ja
die haben immer das ganz cool wirklich
brauchen am ausstand habe ich nicht doch
im und am umstand den die kommt gar
nicht rein in seine neue server so will
ihn zur gesichts hessen macht das die
ganze partie die brauche ich gar nicht
so was machen wir jetzt mal unternehmen
denen ich würde ja ich muss mal ganz
kurz in eure stadt werden und wir müssen
über den friedensvertrag immer dabei
haben irgendwie okay habe ich gar nicht
irgendwo hier rein legen ja du kannst
ihn sogar ein anderes komisches fällt
dagegen recht bei diesen ich weiß gar
nicht was dahin kann eben die ausrüstung
weil ich nicht so ich muss mal ganz kurz
in eure stadt und da sondern links mache
ich trage es ist immer bei meinem herzen
ich muss noch ganz kurz einmal spiegel
portal bei euch seid damit ich nicht
immer das blöde portale benutzen musste
wollte ihr beibringt wie das geld ja
kommen deine stadt überhaupt spiegel
dinge du hast bestimmt welche mal
gefunden irgendwo die kann man nur
finden
die kann man sich aufbauen aber ich habe
ja auch eingebaut und dann ist mir
nachher eingefallen dass ich auch welche
habe ok und sie benutzt man die also du
der spiegel wenn du den hast wenn du den
wenn ich dir jetzt zum beispiel warte
ich hab ja
anstatt blaue spiegel hier magic mirror
müssen jetzt der hand nehmen ist der
hier auf diesem punkt hier fokussiert
bleibt immer plötzlich da der darf aber
kein blog über dir sein
also darf keinen blog über design so
jetzt musst du den spiegel du musst den
spiegel jetzt in der tasche tun also in
den rucksack habe ich den spiegel in
einem rucksack und jetzt bleibt immer da
stehen ja ok bleibt darstellen mache ich
so und jetzt muss ich nämlich irgendwo
hin wo ich im blog über dem kopf ab zb
das ist nur ein halber blog hier die
habe ich jetzt blogger bangkok und jetzt
kann ich in meinen rucksack gehen kann
den spiegel rausnehmen und ich muss
wirklich ein blogger bank kopf haben und
jetzt kann ich ihnen gedrückthalten
macinga la fat wo habt ihr noch mal
euren verzögerungs kaka hat das sonnen
und jetzt kannst du den spiegel
umbenennen zum beispiel auf stadt roth
von der matte geht das nicht dass wir
dem amboss break sollte was ich suche
aber ich hab ich noch nicht habe
statt rot klopf klopf klopf man wird ein
habe ich sonst werde ich immer hierhin
teleportiert ich bin jetzt in der hand
halte so jetzt gehe ich hier auf spiegel
den kann man auch mal easy kräften das
vollständig also nicht von easy aber
schon easy dcp von milli sie von der
diesel macht man tun wenn man ihn auch
nur leicht an haut hey du bist bei mir
unten
ich bin mein haus hier
oha das lagersystem dr
ist das jetzt ist das sei toll
vorgestellten kommen die sachen in die
wertvolle tipps von unten kommt die
kacke hin
ja genau der sc gewonnen wollen wir
haben teil machen warum reiseabenteuer
reichen wollte ich muss erstmal diesem
schicken müller mache nicht mit steve
aber dann werde ich dich schnell laufen
aber ich habe mich hat noch keine the
farmer dass beide arme aus
aber ich hab' wirbelwind sein bin ich
auch schnell wie macht man sich die
versuche ich halt andere lichtquellen
erinnerst du dich du musst du musst
abgeschossen werden wir im winter
medaillen
ja das habe ich gemacht und halte dass
der isi als er da macht man dann laufen
wir herum okay dann entdecken wir ein
bisschen davon hast du dein spiegel
jetzt ja ja gut dann einfach an meiner
hier zuhause okay du musst 2 machten am
besten das aber erst kaufte der geht
kaputt sobald man ihn auch rausholt
hahaha ich habe gerade was gehört bitte
gib mir das tapie so ist das hin wo es
meteorit runter gegangen wo ich habe
keine ahnung oder das nicht gehört
das wasser hier sollen sich auf meinem
dach nein doch nicht altern handle sich
der heftige skelett alter na ja
jeder macht dann dein spiegel einfach
über meinen schädel hat kann das denn
sein
bei euch ist auch alles richtig richtig
geil gebaut als ich lieber eure stadt am
liebsten besser um ein haus dann lasst
ihn nicht rein
es steht einfach nur irgendwo oben auf
dem berg
aber ich bin mit meinem steine benutzt
jetzt bin ich glaube ich war schon
eckstein hier das hinteren eck stellen
alles alles versteckt sein
zieht man es aus der stadt glaube ich
sogar jakub maly nicht all das ist
motivation blog damit alle kinder wählen
ich habe extra stellt drauf
die genesis erstmal junge ein pfeil
brixworth
ich glaube es wird an den pfeil hand
jedoch nicht weil hab ich kann nicht
abschießen gold nein danke wo bist du
ich will nicht nein nein nein einfach
mal gold nuggets wo bist du weder ich
will nicht dass mich ab schießt man noch
so zwei gold- ich werde dich mach die
magic mouse zu sehen kaputt weil er geht
sofort kaputt wenn man ihn auf offenem
himmel hatte nein geht er nicht warum
nicht weil es nicht so ist aber sobald
man ihn raus holt geht ja doch wechselt
er hortete ist dass die neue position
dann oder nicht komm in meine stadt dann
zeige ich dir das also bringen ein
spiegel mit
du kannst auch erstmal durch das portal
gehen ok mache ich hab ich nicht noch
wohin irgendwo wolle gehabt
ich habe alles ok ich muss doch ich muss
trinks haben oder hat luca irgendwo
strings strings gesagt habe ich irgendwo
ganz mir wolle mitbringen okay ich hatte
keine aber keine hätte ich hätte dir
mitgebracht aber leider vom firma her
ist das nicht der fall
ich brauche nur xl ich kannte das ist
dass diese normalen sachen die man im
wandel das hätte aber hier nicht wie
mache ich das denn da brauch ich finde
play
klar habe ich aber das weiß ich merke
ich mir jetzt was fast so das ist statt
druck muss ich irgendwo irgendwas sagen
ich mache ich hier vor ein haus und
denken du musst dich erst mal unter
freiem himmel stellen
ja wenn ich schön und dann hatte ich
kurz ob ich irgendwo kohle habe egal
doch habe ich cool stell dich unter
freiem himmel habe ich ja das war es hey
wieso geht das nicht dann ist schon
fertig clay wie kriegt das clay briggs
dann ist es fertig luca ist es dann
fertig ja jetzt kannst du mir nicht
bieten
jetzt muss in den rucksack tun ja eben
aber wenn ich jetzt wenn ich den
raushole jedoch sofort kaputt wenn ich
nicht unter unter irgendwas drunter
sterne
er geht nicht kaputt er geht nie kaputt
warum nicht weil es nicht so ist lena
aber in einer geht nicht kaputt aber
dann hat eine andere dann ist ja das
stimmt dann stinkt mir eben also welche
nirgendwo fremd bin und dann in meine
stadt möchte und den austausch sehen ihn
rauszuholen bevor ich irgendwo darunter
stehe dann ist ja dass verkackt dass man
aber deswegen sollte du musst es in
einem rucksack mitnehmen musste
das tun ja das mache ich ja kortum okay
du bist einfach im rucksack oder wenn du
irgendwo anders bist irgendwo offene
meer geht zum beispiel auch nicht weil
dann keine blöcke sind außerdem könnten
immer noch unten und dann musst du den
alpinen die benutzen wenn du denn da
irgendwas möchte aber der ist so ich
habe jetzt ein wind medaillon habe ich
noch nicht viel strom
ich komme jetzt zu dir wie lange geht
die folge 1000 minuten 1 16 minuten
okay wir sind denn hier mal irgendwie
skelette oder so kannst du dir dann
wolle mitbringen ich bin schon da ich
habe auch keine volle kannst du dann in
die strings kurz suchen gehen
oder kann es mit dem bogen abschließen
aber bitte nicht töten nicht mit deinem
leben hier den machen einen anderen mann
ist kacke dann mach ich das leider
nehmen hier in bogen zeigt mir kommts
orchester
ja nun mal ich mach mir so kurz war erst
nicht so viel schaden aber ich glaub
ziert genauso ja ok neues lied sich
immer mehr auf ich bin so nett dass die
extra abschießt und so weiter und so
aber voll nett von dir alter richtig gut
den forderungen der wohnung in new york
hilfe der bogen ist kaputt ja wir haben
deine bogen kiste hier mit schlechten
bilden daher kann hier noch ein
ich hab das schon gegen geschmissen ich
weiß einfach dann aktiv
aber es ist doch nicht mehr viel muss
vielleicht du bist so witzig das ist der
aus der kiste
der werfer zaubert of flame aber es ist
normaler bogen
nein aber das lädt dadurch nicht auf
verstöße auf jetzt perfekt er lädt er
nicht auf ich brenne wieder in normalem
wieso brenne ich denn ich dachte ich
habe alte mein kopf ist kaputt deswegen
krieg auch so viel schaden man scheiße
was mache ich denn jetzt aus den kopf
ist kaputt von meiner scale klagte hier
hätte ich das mal repariert was kurz
reparieren
nein man ist das blöd jetzt oder so ich
hatte da eine feier kiste ich brauche
nur einen einzigen feier weichert aller
dir verschwendet ja wir haben eine faire
geste
also darf ich mir einfach rausnehmen
kann zu machen
banco de sabadell ich etwas gesagt ja
ich weiß gibt ja keine schuld aber man
trotzdem traurig bist echt doof da
stehst auch ich beschämt in eine ecke
mit 1010 im rücken ja stimmt ich fühle
mich auch schlecht
wie viele level brauchen unseren atem zu
verzaubern so teuer bestimmt jetzt habe
ich auch wieder keine level hier auch
mal ist das kkd noch hast du ihn wieder
ins geld kopf mich oder so
leider nein aber du kannst dein links
benutzen den kopf hier ja aber da ist er
trotzdem nicht komplett eine
verzauberung dann ja es ist traurig bist
du bist doch mega kicker aus passion
technische schon cool
nein auch das ärgerlich trotzdem muss
ich noch mal ganz kurz abschießen immer
noch cool
lena ich verbrenne ich verbrenne ich
habe darauf immer noch einmal noch
einmal ich schieß extra nicht so doll
ja okay das reicht ist fertig und putz
machen laufen los
dabei könnte sagen wenn die existenzen
sehen dass ich die dann bekommen wir
daraus allerdings machen kann weil du
hast das schon dann das geld einmal
komplettiert ich mich richtig warm
machen
ja aber das ist erst mal wichtig als ich
eine komplette rüstung hat okay so bolt
und wolle weihnachten ist wir dürfen die
frage nicht weiter und wir sind die
partie
freude bis